je reçois aujourd'hui le président des
républicains bonjour christian jacob
bonjour merci d'être avec nous une
première question christian jacob
emmanuel macron a présenté ce matin
france 2030 ce plan d'investissement
destiné à fabriquer les champions de
l'économie française de demain près 30
milliards d'euros vont ainsi riguer la
recherche et différentes entreprises
dans des domaines tels que le nucléaire
le spatial l'aéronautique l'automobile
et même l'exploration des grands fonds
marins alors christian jacob à six mois
de la présidentielle quelle lecture
faites vous de ces annonces la lecture
aller simple président de la république
fait sa campagne électorale avec le
chéquier de la france el cheikh et des
contribuables français on l'a vu sur le
sur le budget et on va le voir tout cet
automne de deux choses l'une soit on est
en face à un budget insincère ce qui a
dénoncé la chambre
la cour des comptes en disant que les
dépenses qui sont annoncées aujourd'hui
ne sont pas financés et ne figure pas
dans le budget donc on a un budget
insincère ou alors le président de la
république ment éhontément c'est-à-dire
fait des annonces en sachant
pertinemment qu'il est incapable dé
financer ce qui ce qui est ce qu'il
annonce sur le nucléaire on envie de se
pincer quand même mais mais mais
rappelez-vous le président de la
république il ya deux ans ou trois ans
en 2000 2018 ya ya un peu plus de un peu
plus de deux ans nous annonçait la
fermeture de 14 réacteurs de 900
mégawatts
ce type de réacteur ça ça produit
l'électricité l'énergie pour pour quatre
cent mille foyers c'est lui qui
l'annonçaient ya trois ans et
aujourd'hui nous dit non on va refaire
du nucléaire c'est se fiche du monde
c'est tout simplement voilà on fait
campagne on y va on prend chez quai des
français et on ouvre les cordons loeb
est ce que vous dites ce que vous
considérez que ceux projetés à 10 ans
pour un président qui est à six mois de
la fin de son quinquennat c'est une
manière dont jambes et les échéant
l'échéance qui arrivent les chances
numéro un donc la présidentielle sinon
même de dépasser le prochain quinquennat
c'est surtout de faire la démonstration
de son incapacité à voir réformer c'est
le premier gouvernement depuis 25 ans
avoir été incapable de mener une réforme
des retraites même françois hollande y
est arrivé même françois hollande est
arrivé mais là incapable de porter une
électrice durée ville entre temps au
christ et non mes trois enfants dans
l'est première année qu'est ce qu'il a
fait et son gilet jaune ils ont été ou
les réformes oui alors on peut parler
des gilets jaunes ont peu parlé de
beaucoup d'autres choses on peut parler
de la sécurité on peut parler de de
l'immigration qui est totalement hors
d'eau hors de contrôle est donc là on
six mois on va tout faire alors que rien
n'a été fait avant le coc vide trop
facile vous dit christian jacob restons
sur la présidentielle parce que pour
vous l'horizon s'éclaircit au moins un
tout petit peu puisque xavier bertrand a
annoncé qu'il rejoindrait le fameux
congrès dlr le 4 décembre on imagine que
c'est forcément un soulagement pour vous
c'est une bonne nouvelle effectivement
c'est la famille la famille de la droite
et du centre qui rassemble et c'est ce
que j'ai souhaité depuis le début je
souhaitais qu'on n'ait pas gagné une
procédure de sélection qui fasse que
tous nos candidats de la droite et du
centre soit rassemblée c'est le cas ce
qui veut dire que le 4 décembre et bien
il y aura un candidat qui portera les
couleurs de la droite et du centre et
donc c'est une très bonne nouvelle
comment ça va se passer christian jacob
pour les militants ont des républicains
parce que c'est eux qui vont choisir le
ou la candidate qui les représentera en
2022 il ne s'agit pas d'une primaire
mais d'un congrès d'un vote interne
concrètement comment ils vont départager
les candidats chacun des des candidats d
un processus de sélection c'est à dire
que chaque candidat doit recevoir au
moins 250 parrainage se dire la moitié
du nombre de parrainages nécessaires
pour être candidat à la présidence de la
république vous savez il faut 500
parrainages de maires ou conseillers
départementaux régionaux la cc 250 et
donc les candidats qui ont recueilli qui
ont recueilli ces parrainages vont avoir
l'occasion à la fois de tourner dans les
fédérations d'aller rencontrer les
militants et puis de présenter leurs
projets leurs propositions on a fait un
gros travail depuis deux ans chez les
républicains on a tout d'abord établi un
projet sur lequel on est d'ailleurs tous
rassemblés d'ailleurs voyez bien qu'il
ya pas de différence fondamentale entre
les propositions des uns et des autres
une manière d'incarner les choses deux
promus et les valeurs qu'il n'y aura pas
de débat entre eux et on sait ce qui pas
de danger s'ils le souhaitent c'est tout
à fait possible si les candidats le
souhaite moi j'y suis tout à fait
favorable à ce stade ci s'est arrêté non
c'est une décision qu'on va prendre avec
eux puisque dd je dis je réunir un
comité d'organisation avec un
représentant de chaque candidat et on va
voir effectivement comment on organise
les débats mais je pense que c'est
plutôt important qui en est justement
les votes internes parfois l'histoire
politique l'a montré dans d'autres
formations politiques en tout cas les
votes internes ne désigne pas forcément
les mieux à même de l'emporter est-ce
que là vous craignais qu'il y ait aussi
un risque sur ce terrain là parce que
xavier bertrand apparaît aujourd'hui
comme le mieux placé pour être qualifié
au second tour or rien ne dit qu'il ne
l'emportent devant les militants nicolas
sarkozy avait été sélectionné par vote
interne c'est un congrès de l'ump qui
lui avait apporté donné le donner
l'investiture
jacques chirac avait recueilli le
soutien du rpr il n'y en congrès pour
être candidat en 95 et ont gagné dans
les hauts cadres également donc et puis
la droite elle gagne quand elle est unie
et rassemblée et le message fort
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir rassemblé tout
le monde et à partir de là moi je suis
très confiant pour les élections
présidentielles je rappelle que depuis
deux ans au delà d'avoir travaillé sur
le fond nous avons gagné toutes les
élections
depuis les européennes perdues nous
avons gagné les municipales
on a gagné les sénatoriales les
législatives partielles les
départementales les régionales donc nous
avons depuis deux ans nous enchaînons
victoire sur victoire donc aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un processus qui
rassemble tout le monde c'est ça qui me
met en confiance effectivement christian
jacob ou dit que la famille rassemblée
et pourtant edouard philippe l'ancien
premier ministre qui était un ancien de
la famille dlr a monté lui soit ils sont
partis politiques william ans à red hat
et oui il l a rejoint emmanuel macron
commencer néanmoins ace que avec ce
nouveau parti politique cette offre pour
le centre droit incarnée par edouard
philippe est ce que vous craignez une au
pea sur la droite vos élus et vos
militants la part de l'ancien premier
ministre absolument retour pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que bon
l'image de trahison d'edouard philippe à
lui colle à la peau
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui abandonne
sa famille politique au milieu du gué
pour aller chercher un siège de premier
ministre pour être à matignon et puis
c'est surtout au delà de ça et de sa
personne c'est son incapacité totale à
réformer je parlais de la capacité à
réformer les retraites la gestion des
finances publiques c'est une gestion
catastrophique selon edouard philippe
pour vous donner un ordre de comparaison
lorsque nicolas sarkozy après la crise
financière de 2010 et est président de
la république les dépenses publiques
augmentent de 1% en moyenne
lorsqu'ensuite françois hollande devient
président de la république et son
gouvernement
c'est 1,4 donc on augmente les dépenses
publiques avec edouard philippe avant qu
vide je parle bien avant que vite ses
2,6 pour cent d'augmentation c'est à
dire c'est sans doute la pire gestion
des finances publiques que nous ayons pu
avoir avec les pourtant c'est lui c'est
lui qui met le feu à la france
les gilets jaunes ont le doigt edouard
philippe le 80 km heure ont le doigt
edouard philippe lorsqu'il faut caler
devant les voyous les casseurs qui
saccagent le centre-ville de nantes et
qui s'oppose à la création de l'aéroport
de notre dame des landes c'est encore
edouard philippe qui cède devant les
voyous et des casseurs dont vous savez
voilà le le passif d'edouard philippe
est très lourd justement on va rester
sur sur ce terrain là sur le terrain la
présidentielle christian jacob parce que
pour l'instant le débat de cette
campagne qui commence et qui s'accélère
c'est surtout déportés à l'extrême
droite avec notamment la concurrence qui
fait rage désormais entre marine le pen
et eric zemmour marine le pen dit
qu'eric zemmour n'est pas un adversaire
quelle est votre position à l'égard du
polémiste qui n'est pas encore candidat
il n'est pas candidat c'est un polémiste
qui joue tantôt sa provocation tentes ou
sur la séduction mais il est une chose
d'être populaire par la polémique et par
le talent personnel qui peut être le
sien il en est une autre d'avoir une
capacité à gouverner a dirigé un pays a
piloté une administration ça c'est une
autre étape autant et la mission à table
la question de l'islam et de
l'immigration et que les républicains
ont souvent pris à leur compte aussi
avec une vraie concurrence avec le front
national 6 on est pas sur une
concurrence on est sur des solutions à
apporter c'est pour ça que nous avons
travaillé sur notre sur notre projet est
aujourd'hui eric zemmour est dans le
constat et l'incantation et puis il ya
certes le sujet bien évidemment de
l'immigration c'est un vrai sujet
d'ailleurs nous y apportons nous des
réponses mais il y a aussi tout ce qui
intéresse les français au quotidien le
pouvoir d'achat la santé la formation
des jeunes pourquoi on a un tel taux de
chômage des jeunes en france remettre en
cause notre notre système éducation
notre système de formation tous ces
sujets là doivent être pris à bras le
corps et nous devons un candidat à la
présidentielle se doit de faire des
propositions là dessus au depuis même
sur la laïcité la laïcité c'est la
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire ça
n'est pas le rejet d'une religion par
rapport à une autre c'est l'obligation
que chacun puisse croire ou ne pas
croire mais
respecte les lois de la république
c'est ça le sujet sur désigner une
religion à la vindicte populaire je suis
pas sûr que l'on voit bien je dirais
l'écho médiatique sa place cela peut
avoir mais il faut je dirais travailler
avec lire une idée beaucoup plus saine
sur le plan républicain c'est-à-dire
faire en sorte que chacun ait la même
chance en revanche chacun et
l'obligation de respecter les règles de
la république quand vous voyez que
marine le pen et eric zemmour dans les
sondages sont après 30% des intentions
de vote ça dit quelque chose de l'état
de la france aujourd'hui en quelques
mots et après il y aura une dernière
question oui alors après
ça peut dire quelque chose aujourd'hui
sur l'inquiétude c'est d'abord c'est
l'échec des manuels macron ses dix ans
de gauche ces cinq ans de françois
hollande ces cinq ans emmanuel macron et
à chaque fois que vous avez une période
de gauche ou de centre gauche pour
reprendre et emmanuel macron et bien ça
se traduit effectivement par un
renforcement des extrêmes et ça n'est
jamais le cas lorsque la droite est au
pouvoir le front national n'est jamais
assez niveau ni l'extrême gauche un
dernier mot christian jacob pour
conclure cette interview vous publié
chez robert laffont j'en ai tellement vu
et ce que j'ai appris du pouvoir on va
voir là la couverture de votre livre à
l'écran christian jacot finalement
est-ce que l'une des leçons de cette
expérience politique c'est que rien
n'est écrit à l'avancé dans tous les
ports trick vous brosser dans ce livre
là c'est vrai c'est la particularité de
la politique vous savez ce que disait
pierre dac les prévisions sont souvent
fausses notamment lorsqu'elles portent
sur l'avenir mais au delà de au delà de
cela en ce que j'essaie de faire
partager dans ce livre c'est
l'expérience qui est la mienne 40 ans de
vie publique dans le syndicalisme
pendant 16 17 ans ensuite dans la vie
politique à la fois dans les fonctions
compter les miennes dans mes fonctions
ministérielles deux présidents de groupe
de présidents de parti mais aussi de
maires d'élus d'élu local différentes
rencontres que j'ai pu avoir voilà c'est
c'est une expérience que j'avais envie
de envie de faire partager finalement si
on reste sur ce sur ce livre est ce ce
travail finalement que ce témoignage que
vous nous livrez christian jacob est-ce
que vous rester confiant dans la chose
politique parce que l'image est
politique a été très sérieusement abîmée
ces dernières années oui mais ce que
l'on peut dire aussi c'est que l été
réhabilités sur le plan local voyez dans
la période de crise sanitaire nous avons
vécu heureusement que les mères étaient
là heureusement c'est un oui très
clairement ça toutes les failles la cse
président de la république et ses
ministres qu'ils nous aient tout et leur
contraire je veux dire du d'une journée
à l'autre pour pas dire d'une heure à
l'autre
ont changé de cap en permanence ce qui
ont été solide pendant la crise c'était
les collectivités territoriales c'est
d'ailleurs un enseignement à tirer moi
je suis clairement favorable à ce que
les maires puissent devenir
parlementaire comme c'était le cas
auparavant fin du cumul des mandats
voilà aujourd'hui cette expérience de
maire d'élus de terrain manque au
parlement et ce qui a fait aussi que
l'actuel président de la république
edouard philippe pour le site est aussi
sur ce sujet ont traité avec un mépris
sans pareil le parlement et si on veut
réhabiliter le parlement mettant des
gens qui ont effectivement cette
expérience de terrain faisant en sorte
que les maires puissent à nouveau être
député ou sénateur merci beaucoup
christian jacob d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur ce plateau et l'info
continue sur tv7
[Musique]